Pro Football Hall of Famer had read back
here on the Rich Eisen show how are you
Ed I'm good I'm doing fine look at you
part of the paparazzi ed look at you hey
man no come to the dark side
oh my word
so what Ravens team did you find last
week coming off for that loss in
Cleveland how were they when you walked
in there I mean those guys will be you
know ready for the week excited to go to
Pittsburgh and you know that's what we
saw we I think I think those young guys
got a great playoff and championship
atmosphere you know kind of I guess you
could say test you know for what they
got coming forward for what they're
looking for you know no matter no matter
like I told them no matter the schedule
I mean a record of either team that's
gonna be a tough playoff environment you
know so it that's that's what make that
rivalry so good you know and and and
mayor Hines actually talked about this
when we did our arm interview before I
was behind the unit I'm not sure but up
in Pittsburgh we did a ride-along and me
and I talked about that that arm series
that rivalry being whoever came out of
that we had a great chance of being in
the playoffs and making that run to get
a championship so I guess then let me
ask from what you could glean again I
know you were you were with the team
leading up to the game what type of team
is this I can't I can't figure it out I
mean they they were offensively dynamic
the first two weeks of the season Kansas
City they handled its business against
them and obviously we know it is a tough
place to win even though Indianapolis
did it
Cleveland punked him and then in
Pittsburgh Mason Rudolph that is a way
to look at it I mean they really did jam
it down their throat at I say it with
the ultimate respect even though punking
sounds disrespectful but I
Pittsburgh with two backups almost you
know got it done so what what type of
team do you think these Ravens are still
a young team and still growing
you know the quarterback is young though
he's making plays he still have a lot to
learn you know you got it was offensive
coordinators just there for the first
time great Roman so this is a lot of
stuff that they're still ironing out you
know you got a bunch of guys on defense
who are still getting to know each other
so they're building that camaraderie you
know I might see a bunch of those guys
out in Baltimore when I go they're just
at dinner you know they eating dinner
together trying to build that
camaraderie so it's like um some of the
earlier years that I had there you know
just trying to get that camaraderie
built to where you have a solid team you
know and that's what it's about doing
this and you know so they building the
right weight that coaches building that
team the right way man always had a
chance to be in the playoffs and that's
all you can ask for to be to be a
winning team and get to the dance and
have a chance to fight for that
championship so what you know so what go
what growing pains do you think Lamar
Jackson is going through right now I
mean you can see like this just making
the right decisions really you know and
and put that position protecting
yourself it's definitely something
that's always going to be talked about
for a running quarterback there any
quarterback is all about protection in
the hits that he's taken you know and
you know Lamar Lamar has some moves man
Lamar's are very savvy you know a smooth
player out there on that football field
you can see that he stops on a dime you
know and I think he has an entertainer
not to take those hits but as a running
quarterback and want to be successful
you know once you get that ball in your
hand I know how us as athletes you know
you want to score you want to get them
extra yards for your for your team you
know arm as I used to do you know when I
got interception you can see us pitching
the ball and doing kind of stuff like
that and that's what I'm saying you you
don't want just that that football
player to come out of Lamar and he'd
take one of those
you know Robert Griffin you know hit me
that Robert Griffin is on the team you
know all one of those Michael Vick hit
you know so you want him to be a smart
player I want him to be a smart player
you know like a Russell Wilson you know
like like a Donovan McNabb was you know
making those those smart decisions you
know and throwing the ball right you
know I mean you you make bad throws at
times we all do all quarterbacks do you
know even the best you know and breathe
Brady and Peyton you know maybe bad
throws you know so you know it's just
like I said there's those those growing
pains he has to learn you know working
that pocket and Reed Pro Football Hall
of Famer here on the Rich Eisen show
speaking of quarterback hits what did
you think of the one that Earl Thomas
laid on Mason Rudolph I'd read you know
he was just doing this job Rudolph held
it as long as he could and when he got
rid of it you know it's a bang-bang
thing that's something I talk about with
concussions and all that you know you
can't take that out of football you know
especially when you're giving guys
helmets with your weapons you're giving
them shoulder pads with your weapons you
know and you got one guy on your back
another guy in your front trying to
block the ball and then he gets pushed
he gets pushed forward by the guy on his
back and you know into Earl and you know
yeah I was explaining this to some guys
yesterday you think about a boxer right
you watch javante David's 1/2 pound
final best boxers out right now on the
champ if he if he if that a guy that
guy's going to throw his hands up his
head is gonna drop he's gonna try to
protect himself and that's what that's
what anybody would do if they're about
to get hit that's what anybody would do
if they're hitting somebody you know
they protect themselves so it's hard to
change that natural human movement in
anybody and we're trying to find we're
finding people for that you know so it's
a it's a really testy thing you know and
other things need to change besides
rules but like what like like like the
contracts for the NFL player you know
you're talking about educating kids
educating parents on what they what
their child is coming into you want kids
to play football we want more kids to
play football you know in our you
right but we're doing it wrong at the
NFL on level you know we're teaching
wrong at the NFL level you know we're
teaching wrong at the higher level we
want them to do it right but we're
teaching wrong at the higher level so
you know we we need to put it in the
contract if you play NFL football you
play football these are the consequences
that's choices and consequences in life
to everything there's consequences if
you play football those consequences are
CTE concussions
you know um death you know these are the
things that come from it put it in the
contract because people know that's what
it is
you understand put it in the contract
and let people know and then we go from
that knowledge they understand that
they're made the choice to play this
violent game and we don't have to tweak
the rules for anything it stays the same
game you know for the most part of what
we've come from the pavers paid that way
so our you know are you suggesting just
so I understand I change the liability
lines in the contract so that the
players when they put their contract
their name on a contract they understand
that they're putting their health at
extreme risk potentially and therefore
the NFL can just say hey the rules are
now old-school is that what you're
saying yes yes sir this is football this
is how football is played you know this
is how football was played you know not
making rules area NFL putting rules
every year and all those rules are set
in place it's to punish the people
that's what lawmakers do they set these
rules in the NFL to punish the player to
take money from the player when half
these players more than half the players
in the league can't afford this stuff
and read Pro Football Hall of Famer here
on the Rich Eisen show we just played
the speech that that Harbaugh had you
give to the team you didn't even have
any prep prep work on that one you just
spoke from the head read heart right
there no but you know I never in all my
years and giving speeches from high
school
College and University of Miami and even
in Baltimore I kind of go off of what I
feel and without seat you know a little
bit of what I know and and just give a
speech from the heart man that way those
guys should it they know well I'm coming
from I played against Pittsburgh a bunch
of times so it wasn't hard you know for
that that that dislike that hate to come
out you know and give it to some young
guys who are in my shoes where I used to
be huh and so um do you want to coach
still because it's a head coach HC HC
every yeah I've been around a lot of
great coaches I've been around a lot of
great organizations for his University
in Miami even my desperate high school
and in Baltimore I learned a lot being
around a bunch of coaches I can name a
bunch of coaches I've played under have
worked with and all of these
relationships and partnerships I'm
talking about coach Davis Curtis Johnson
art Kehoe Dyer solid Chuck Pagano coach
Heart Ball Coach Billick Mike Smith no
right um Mike Nolan you know Terrell
Austin I've seen a lot of coaches bro
you know so that's what's up oh good to
meet you I've been around a lot of great
coaches that helped me to develop and to
the player to the man to the coach that
I am that I became there's a reason why
I was known to be a coach on a football
field you know because I was more like a
Bill Belichick to make adjustments
during the game you know and uh Toronto
rich you know I mean I wish I can get to
a great situation you know they seem to
be giving giving coaches second chances
who don't do nothing in certain
organizations and they go to another
organizations you expect the same
results that's insane that's the family
ain't it rich I know but I'm sure you've
heard it that because you you need
seasoning as an actual coach first edy
right I got I got twelve seasons in me I
got three championships two coaches flag
football of my son and I realize
mouthing and Buffalo sure and I realized
coaching in Buffalo
and the spill I had in New York is that
those same kids I'm coaching and my
son's like football game but they're the
same kid done in an NFL Rich you know so
it's not a complicated game you know I
understand what all these coach they're
seasonal and all that but for the stuff
that they do that takes 90 hours a week
takes me and my crew maybe 60 or 70 you
know the stuff that some of these
coaches do with some of these
organizations you know there's a reason
why some of them don't or most of them
haven't gotten to that stage where you
see them making the playoffs year after
year or even five years later you know
you got guys that haven't been in the
playoffs in 10 20 years crazy you know
what's really going on so they need
somebody like myself in these
organizations you know who know football
you know not just on the field but off
the field as well you know there's a
reason why I was known as a leader on
and off the field you know and of course
that stuff I would need to learn you
know but what coach would coach is not
learning on the job what person is not
learning on the job
you know you've been fool if you wasn't
learning on a job well I guess you're
looking I'm looking right now while
we're having a conversation ed Reed here
a few more minutes left with the Hall of
Famer I always love our chats I'm
sitting here thinking Aaron Boone of the
Yankees was in the booth for ESPN and
now he's in the ALCS and you're seeing
in basketball some guys just get a gig
when they're done playing sometimes just
strolling into head coaching gigs right
Steve Kerr right Juwan Howard my head
coach at Michigan was wasn't assistant
for many many years but I'm just
wondering like it seems in football that
they'll never seemingly just take a
player and just a Pro Football Hall of
Fame player and just throw on the
sideline is an HC and in the NFL and
that that's a tall order don't you think
that's their loss rich and when they do
it they will see you know they learn
something about themselves you know but
I'm out smoking God been outspoken
always this you know and always said the
NFL jury reflection of our country so
there you have it you know there's a
reason why they don't do certain things
there's a reason why when I was in
Buffalo certain coaches who names I
won't say looked at me as a player and
not a coach was very disrespectful you
know it was very disheartening when I'm
coaching better than you are you know
you teach them by the book I can teach
by the book
in coaching you know technique and all
that stuff so I know what I could do I
know my capability you know um I've been
through what they call the gauntlet I've
been around these coaches I've sat in
coaches meetings on Mondays and Tuesdays
I got coaches that can vouch for that
you know I got coaches I can vouch for
that
you know so I'm not I'm not really
concerned about not having certain time
you know with arm with the teams and
stuff like that you know there's a
reason why I'm doing the grind the show
with you right you know because there's
that so respect their own on it as a
football player to where he somebody
knows he can be an analyst but going
there and critique film and look at it
from a different perspective so the
resume is built on rich why also know I
also know Belichick thinks extremely
highly of you and we've seen NFL Films
footage of Brady and Belichick game
planning just for you knowing what
you've done
X's and O's wise and what you're capable
of doing least I know that that's
because I am gonna put the time in the
study to know my opponent you know I am
gonna put that work in so that's one
thing that organization will be able to
count on is that he's gonna put the work
in all right before I let you go Wow was
that to be honored at the bone Akane
fund that is a significant honor that
you received at what was that like for
your brother I was going truly a
blessing to live blessing and honor to
be their rich I mean I've been doing a
banach honor family since 2002 my agent
gene motto
he's in baseball now I'm introducing me
to him brought me over there to plan a
golf tournament and it was heartfelt
rich it really was heartfelt Cris
Collinsworth was their good friend and
you know to represent a brother
hall-of-famer arrest his Pete rested so
mr. Nick Buoniconti for what he's done
for many people not just for his son but
for many people you know it's
inspirational rich
it's truly inspirational you know and
and I totally support those guys man
mark born akane man that guy there's you
know it's so special man for the things
he's continuing to do with his family
and and and supporters you know the
Miami project you know mr. Bart green
you know who I know personally I had to
see him for nerve impingement I had seen
that same one that Payton had surgery on
you know I went to see him and he you
know helped me to get through my
situation you know so you got a bunch of
great people that are working with that
foundation man and I encourage people to
look them up and go and vote I mean
going donate to that fun you know if you
got a dollar two dollars and don't
matter every dollar helps you know
because I had two uncles that was you
know paralyzed man from from waist down
I mean from arm from neck down and you
know as a kid growing up you're not you
don't know you know you don't know it
and quite frankly this is back in the
early eighties rich where you know my
family did not have you know the means
to help them you know to get them help
you know so I'm thankful to see
something like this years later not
knowing what God had prepared for me to
be in that situation to be around people
like that you know so as a reason for
everything rich well congrats it's so
well deserved and and I'm so thrilled
that you did NFL the grind I hope you
keep doing it when I heard that you were
doing it I'm like perfect it's perfect
your person anytime rich a moment where
you make the call man we we I will come
in anytime wherever you at
we can give them a little karaoke and I
know that about us but we can do that is
right you're the best dad I love you I
don't care who knows it you're the best
right I love you too brother
right back at you that's ed Reed at 20
ER on Twitter at the number 20 and then
the word 20 ER on Instagram for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app